75% of Americans believe there are events
that cannot be explained.
Over half of them are
celebrities.
Noises, shapes, shadows.
Hello? Weird dolls.Ghost hands.
Uh-oh.
Bye!
As a celebrity,
I'm not superstitious, but I do assume
that everything I don't
understand is black magic.
This was the first vacation
I booked since I got famous,
so I wanted to treat myself
to a fancy hotel.
(bell chimes)
(laughing)
Just having
a bit of fun. In the past, I've always stayed
at motels where the door
to my room opens
directly to the parking lot,
which is cool 'cause you can
check on your car.
But this time, I was looking
forward to being treated
better than other people.
I don't have to tip
'cause I have this.
Bye.
Yes.
The first night, I met a really
chill couple from the Keys,
who, like me, were
down for whatever.
We should go have sex
with each other.
Then, at the last minute,
they had a change of heart.
No hard feelings.
And if they change their mind,
like, they know where I am.
In the morning,
I woke up to a strange sound.
It was like...
(knocking)
(knocking continues)
It was like a door noise
but on the other side...
...of the door.
What?
When I opened the door,
a "USA Today"
had appeared on the floor.
So I was like, um,
"Okay, that's weird."
Like, now it's weird.
I was bugging out.
So I went into town
to do a Segway tour
and score some
Caribbean Adderall.
When I get back,
the first thing
I notice is that my towel
has been transformed
into a swan.
And then I see that
on top of my pillow
is an even tinier pillow
made entirely of chocolate.
And now I know
there's a ghost.
I know.
I tested my ghost theory by
dumping out all of the shampoo
and drinking all of
the bottles from the mini bar.
I remember thinking, like,
"Let's see
a ghost deal with this."
But then I bounced out
and I ran into the guy
who had sold me
a shark tooth necklace.
And just crashed
at his place.
It was cool.
He had a snake.
When I got back, I was almost
too scared to open the door.
All the bottles
were full again.
And the room was spotless.
I just broke down.
I called my personal life
coach and psychic, Cheyakee.
There's a (bleep) swan here!
I've known Amy for 12 weeks and
if she says she saw a ghost and
agrees to fly me down
business class,
then guess what,
she saw a ghost.
(knocking)
That's the door noise
I told you about.
(woman)
Mrs. Schumer!
What do you want
with us, spirit?
(woman)
Hello, housekeeping.
You're not
welcome here!
(woman)
Okay, thank you.
I come back.
(screaming)
Oh God!
(Amy)
I checked out that day.
I guess there are more forces
out there than meets the eye.
And sometimes, those
forces bring us swan towels.